season 3 of Microsoft's fighting game
killer instinct will kick off March 29th
this is also the same day the game will
arrive on PC through Windows 10 you'll
have to wait a little longer for pricing
details and pre purchase options but we
should be getting more detail shortly
eight new characters in total will be
released in season three classic
fighters Kim Lou and tusk rash from
battletoads and the arbiter from Halo
will be available when season 3 kicks
off the remaining unannounced for will
come later this year if you've already
played killer instinct on xbox one all
your progress will follow you to the
windows 10 addition additionally it was
confirmed that xbox 360 fight sticks
will be compatible with season three on
PC at launch while Xbox one fight six
support will come sometime later if you
do plan on picking this up on PC be sure
to check out the minimum specs for more
information on killer instinct season 3
head over to the game's official website
and for more gaming news you're already
in the right place